est ce que quelqu'un sait et on les
mauvaises langues disent que le jury
était chargé pour les questions de
budget que les logeant moins cher c'est
vrai c'est beau c'est vrai mais les
salaires estimés pour les coaches et
année julien clerc et soprano 350000
euros
un génie shirt jennyfer 600 mille huit
cent mille obispo 500000 asie 500 1000
et à 900 milles la saison dernière j'ai
déjà c'est ça la non parce que faites
vous quand même remettre dans leur
contexte vraiment l'argent qu'ils
découvrent ces sommes là ils doivent
être démagogique par les compagnies 30
ans il faut pas qu'ils se plient gagne
ça je dis juste que c'est des sommes qui
sont hallucinantes j'espère c'est
évidemment je peux et je termine juste
ma phrase
moi aussi je pense quoi ya pas mal de
gens qui en avaient ras-le-bol de voir
florent pagny zazie qui sont
effectivement deux grands artistes
enfin à bout d'un moment trop de florent
pagny trop jazzy on les avait trop bu
c'est aussi bien de rajeunir le jury moi
ça me fait plaisir de voir son côté
renault ajoute aussi mois fléchir est de
street credibility c'est un peu plus
humble de pratiquer un peu de hip hop
dans cette émission est une très bonne
chose mais c'est quand même cool donc ça
rajeunit et julien clerc et paraît qu'il
a été très long parce que je connais
quelqu'un parte et attention le lifting
était nécessaire c'était obligé parce
qu'effectivement on était tous un peu
lassé de l'émission et de la mécanique
mais là ils prennent quand même un
tournant téléréalité à mort avec leurs
nouvelles règles à la kolontar plus les
portraits des candidats qui sont de plus
en plus télé réalité il faut que le mec
il est perdu son père et sa mère qui
nous fasse bien vous me parler après et
là je la saisis voilà le but je vous ai
dit vous avez vu quelqu'un de connu ward
autre inconnue qu'est dans l'épisode wii
à gages
qu'est ce qui m a rien et cornet il ya
une petite dizaine d'années qui a fait
quelques tubes il sera apprécié il est
extraordinaire dans de meilleurs talents
de cette saison après évidemment qui
scénarise un peu plus ils ont besoin les
téléspecteurs talent et à intervalles
s'attacher au tard le vous parlez de la
crs scénarisation j'ai vu le portrait
mois qu'ils ont diffusé
on se rapproche quand même petit à petit
vers les codes qu'on fait moi je pense
que à la base qui fait cette émission
est une douce il ya eu un tremblement de
terre en haïti tous les 6 10 des mamans
se réalise en fait que la famille c'est
important parce que t'en as qu'une fois
du coup bah j'ai arrêté la musique c'est
beaucoup de sacrifices
c'est c'est pas un truc qui fascine
ça a été un vide dans la vie gage
vous êtes quelqu'un de courageux parce
qu'on revenir dans la lumière comme un
débutant et c'est une preuve d'humilité
si vous êtes placé pour les bonnes
raisons exactement
[Applaudissements]